at this makeshift camp
everything's a struggle
[Music]
families forced to flee a wave of
taliban attacks in helmand province
now squatting in a half-built vegetable
market
her mother explains how their home
became a front line
as taliban forces attacked government
troops three weeks ago
the governor even says militants linked
to the terrorist group al-qaeda
took part in the assault a claim the
taliban strongly denies
um
british forces spent eight years in
helmand fighting the taliban
but their core goal was to stop al-qaeda
from ever again having a safe haven in
the country
the taliban pledged to cut ties with the
group as part of a peace deal with the
united states
signed in february in qatar
evidence that's not happening would be a
serious blow
in helmand the recent clashes forced up
to 35
000 people to flee their homes
some weren't fast enough
casualties surged at the main trauma
hospital
these families aren't the only ones
suffering as there's violence across the
country
the government has started historic
peace talks with the taliban
but life for now remains hostile
debrahing sky news